hey guys it's max with max tech today
I'll be showing you how you can very
easily install and upgrade the RAM and
the brand new 2019 5k iMac and this
tutorial will also work for 2017 2015
and 2014 I max as well a lot of people
complain saying that these are expensive
machines and they only come with eight
gigs of ram standard even if you're
buying a very expensive model like this
one I hear which costs over $3,000 but
there is a huge benefit and that is you
can save up to six hundred and eighty
dollars if you upgrade and install the
RAM yourself it's very easy to do and
unlike what some people say it does not
void your warranty at all in fact Apple
actually has a step-by-step install
guide on their website showing you how
to do it the greater the total amount of
RAM that you want to get in your system
the more savings that you get you guys
can see that little chart right there
and we'll have links to the RAM that we
used in the video description but
there's also a few configurations that
you can do yourself the Apple doesn't
offer and I'll talk about that closer to
the end of this video so let's get right
into it let's start out by shutting down
the Machine and then unplugging it from
the wall and then removing the cable
there you go and the slot that we're
gonna access is actually hidden right
behind the stand here right next to the
power cable port we have this little
button that releases this kind of
trapdoor you do need to press down quite
a bit for it to start popping up and we
might do this a few times and then
you'll see that it's going to start
popping up you want to grab and pull up
and that gives us the access to the RAM
slots next we have these retention clips
so you want to push out and then you'll
have access to your RAM I'm gonna grab
these with two fingers pull up and they
slide right out and it'll do the next
one as well if you're only adding two
more sticks of RAM you can leave those
in there and just slide in the new
additional RAM but I'm adding a whole
set of Ram and if you grab your new set
you'll see that this little cutout is
actually offset so you want the longer
portion to be towards the right side if
you're sitting the same way I am and the
shorter portion to the left and these
will only go in one way so once you
start putting them in these little slots
here that are cut out if it's not
seating improperly you don't need to put
too much force so you just want to make
sure that
you're aligning him properly and if
you're looking at angle you actually see
the little tab there so I slide it down
push just gently and it's gonna give you
a nice little click let's do the next
one
there we go
third and fourth
now that they're all in there I'm just
gonna grab these tabs push down out
slightly and they'll lock this whole
thing in we can grab our little cover
align it properly here and press down
each four corners and there we go it's
installed now let's go ahead and lift up
our Mac and plug it back in as you can
see we now have 64 gigabytes of RAM and
in just a few minutes we saved six
hundred and eighty dollars and we still
have our full Apple warranty if you have
Apple care it's not gonna affect it at
all so we'll have links to the RAM in
the video description and at the start
of the video I said that there's a few
configurations that you can do yourself
that you can't actually get from Apple
the first one is if you just want 24
gigs of ram you can actually keep the a
gigs that comes with add two more eight
gigs sticks you have 24 gigs and that's
enough for most people if you're just do
an email web surfing you use Chrome you
watch movies maybe even simple video
editing with final cut 1080p videos with
simple effects that's going to be
perfect not such a good deal instead of
spending two hundred dollars from Apple
to get an additional eight gigs of RAM
on top of that if you're a medium to
heavy user you can actually add to six
of 32 gigabytes that's going to give you
40 gigabytes total and that's more than
enough for most people of course you can
do what we did and jumped up to 64 with
to get two sets of 32 but what's even
crazier is that this iMac the new 2019
version actually supports 128 gigabytes
of RAM and Apple does not offer that
we'll have a link in the video
description where you can buy a set it's
just a little bit more expensive than
what Apple charges for 64 gigabytes and
you get 128 gigabytes other than this
system you have to jump up to like an
iMac pro to be able to get that and with
that Mac Pro you can't upgrade the RAM
yourself and give it a couple months I
think that price is gonna drop on those
large high-capacity RAM sticks and
you'll be able to get 128 for less than
the price that Apple charges for 64 so
thank you guys for watching if you have
any questions you can ask in the
comments section below this been max max
tech hit that little circle if you want
to see more videos like this one and
I'll see you in the next one
[Music]